[音楽]
5分
ございません
バッハ
[拍手]
えっ
ています
yeah
[音楽]
なぜこりゃー
母親ああ
待ってくれよ
なんだここ
だって俺さっきまでパソコンこれでカタカタカタカタってやつの日産だか吸い込まれ
たら変な場所に行ってさー
なにこれなにこれを a
これって族 new
異世界転生地やつかなぁあっはっは
俺なんか
バーチャルユーチューバーになったみたいだねぇ
たぶんそうだと思うよくわかんないけど多分これバーチャル肇社長ですよ
白衣着てるもこれ白衣着てろ
[音楽]
ですよねーやべよ
俺多分
バーチャル融通がになっちゃったん
大体も思ってる動かせやすいなぁ
を
鳳凰
動かせやすい
ああ
すごいなんでこんなにバーチャル世界という動きや製品化
えません
どうやって戻るんだろういやぁなんとなってくださいバーチャル世界にキャンのはいい
んですけど
待っておれどうやってここから現実世界に戻ればいいの
どうすよ
どうしよう
戻れないよ
ですえーオーデータ
[音楽]
もうどうやって変えるんだよ
やって来は家内もどこか
帰れないの
んだこれ
誰か
形がいませんか
なぜか
[音楽]
待っているまったくを待ってください待ってください
待って
すいません
待って全然話きかないんですけど待ってください
マニー
てっぱん本漫画12紹介したプロあのー
何えっ
見ない顔やねぇいやーそうなんですよ茨城キャンってやってください
未来あかりさんですか
皆さん1名別誤ってくださいよ
悪い
ねぇこれけっこう者のみがいなくなったんですよ
続き初めまして音です
いやーも有名でもバターリウッツィ馬体ではもう
んでー yeah
うーんなる二重三昧でもいるああああああ
ああああああああ
tan
転勤なしかギャあの僕もいつユーチューバーやってるんですけどどうなんでしょ
はじめましてあのすごいシャベルですねあかりさん音声ちょっと困ってることがあるん
ですけど
ドアの僕バーチャル世界の人じゃないんですよ
はいパソコン書いてる方々方って言ったら
ぱそこに入っちゃってああ
気付いたらここにいたんですよアジャ人間界
あそうですだろ
今感触どころかいやぁよく来ちゃんが困ってるんですって
ああ
もらえるの
を知ってるかわかんないんですけど僕
はじめしたといいます
ハーフ
おいしいいいいい
ユーチューバーのトッまあそうなりますけど
ますをなりますけど
僕はドルト君をいう場ではむやみを大人になるって大嵐でみてくださいこの池も絶対
イクなッ
っていうのなんしょんですよ
あることは初め邪教立ち位置よあじゃあ多分あいさつしたら分かりそうな気がするん
ですよね
ana
いきます
こんにちははじめ社長です
爽やかじゃないみたいな今日じゃ
確かにてますそれかしなきゃいいでしょ
本人でじゃあ薄くなってくださいよ
あ
保管
おい聞いたりて大丈夫か
大丈夫だ大丈夫
お前大丈夫か
宮瀬俺もないのだ左足そうだ
キレイああ
左足がいない
バーチャル世界ってこういうところですかなはっはっは
あいややっと煎じてくださいありがとうございます
キュッ4 aw ものがベター
今満開さんずっとそうだったんですけど入っ
神社のん
これどうしてやってられるんですかいやれないよねーうーん
えってぃさあ
この次回はさ
人間界とはも繋がってない
にっ
[音楽]
女件
初めて中
ごめんねっ
諦めて
んああああ
me
[音楽]
ana
ん
ほりっ
が寝られるんですかあああ
ああーよかっでもやせっかくバーチャル世界に来たんで
どうせだったらこの世界の最もんしみたいんですよ
よかったら
あかりさんの日時にしてくれませんかね
同じくん
[音楽]
youtube の先輩は
アニメラー[ __ ]ジャンちゃうと思って書いてるんですよ
カナダ今一生寝ちゃったんですけど今回書いてあったよ
この世界では朝に船体が先輩なんですよ
家まで待って6 youtube
怒号あ
ついて解りの方が強いよいや違うんですよ
この世界では先輩としたよちょっと北に
バー全世界のことを教えてほしいんですよ
[音楽]
堀田中教えるけど
昼黒登録者を増やす方もしていた分かりますここってちなみにわかり先輩の家ですか
あっ
変化車欲しいんじゃ終わってください違うんです
いやー
違うんですよいいいい
いやあまいってなきゃいけばれてるんですよ疑問だ
ハイフォンやろこのパン中
[音楽]
d 3
にっ
希望
ジャンピー幕
これ答えなきゃいけないですか
はい
goo
t バッケその頃
あの
動きエロい
[拍手]
ええええええ
ガッツリ芯折れちゃったはいはいじゃあマンナンティアナにいい
ピアもこう世界では先輩なんで
義務霧島山でございましたーっ
抱き読むにまじかた名字ですはいぜひ
ですよろしくです時の先輩今日はこの辺でお暇させていただきます
早い
はーやれよパール杯坊主いつでも遊びに行きます
やったばいばーい一番って書いたらしいんだよ
しかも持ってほしいわかりましただけでいいはい
他5名で帰ります
以上まん
ハッピーん
ちょっとわからないっすよ
んじゃになりながら心を入っていくと
本当ですかそうでは前半また逢う日まで
から順に違いにも覗い
[音楽]
をプレイしました
me
me あった